[Music]
on this episode of travel dares I'm
taking AJ to the beaches of Mont
saint-michel to learn how to escape
quicksand and I'm taking Caroline to
Lima Peru aah
to learn how they make the world's
fluffiest omelet come join us on our
adventures on this episode of travel
dares welcome to travel dares last
season I traveled all around the US with
my friend Joe this season I'm taking two
new friends all across Europe to explore
more exciting activities on today's
episode we're here in northern France
with my friend AJ
Bonjour AJ so how excited are you
I'm so excited Caroline right here is
your clue all right
this Dare will make your stomach sink
you're gonna have a great time AJ loves
unique activities that are filled with
adrenaline and this is one of the only
places in the world where you can learn
how to escape quicksand before we get to
your dare you have to take off your
shoes no I think that sink is like a
literal I'm going to sink well don't
worry
joy what is this one likes to go all
right AJ take off your blindfold we're
at Mont saint-michel and we're gonna
learn how to escape Oh oh my gosh what
oh look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
so I am a guide to for today on I will
show you have a quick sound around the
way to get out all right let's do it
[Music]
I think we're getting really close
oh I think we're here okay so so we stop
here okay
and we've jump and I will show you how
to get out okay okay I'm done you can
try all right I'm ready right close to
get up okay huh jump Alexis let's go for
a pee on the side now I'm going down
it's all the water is going out mm-hmm
and then you have all little Sun around
your legs okay
and then it's like a concrete they'll
try to take off I don't understand okay
so how you have to move your legs like
this okay
twist twisting oh I'm gonna crush
Caroline in this sand quicksand
competition I am so ready for this I'm
really excited actually I cannot wait oh
yes oh yes we will
it's my turn I'm going down okay so
let's go to jump right we can help to go
down okay like this like this yeah my
legs are stuck oh my gosh I'm freaking
out
okay start the timer just one yeah and
then oniony yes the opposite way we lost
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's go to jump all right start the
timer all right all right
it was a very surreal feeling like I
couldn't move anything yeah but then
when you start twisting it really like
starts loosening up all ready to go back
yeah ready okay let's go all right AJ
what did you think of that
ah Carolyn I think that's gonna go down
as one of the best experiences I've ever
had it was so much fun
you like it you ready for your clue I'm
so ready I'm so ready okay let's get
cracking okay I wonder what that means I
have no idea I do have a surprise what's
it's right through there through here
seriously okay no yeah totally let's go
now I'm a bit of a food expert and I met
who law is known for making the world's
fluffiest omelet
making the perfect omelet is extremely
difficult and I'm excited to see if
Caroline is up to the task
[Music]
all right perfect
hold out your hand just hold it out
there you go
be very careful what is it oh it be very
careful I'm careful okay
okay take off your blindfold
we're learning how to make the world
fluffiest oh my god wait this is not
what I was expecting at all you're gonna
love this it's all so good it's not so
good Oh earth funk is gonna show us how
it's made and then me and you are gonna
have a little competition let's see who
can make the better omelet okay I'm
gonna win this one I think I'm a really
good chef I don't know about that yeah I
do
look how bubbly and if I could get the
inside part of us to bubble it is
kind of push off oh okay it's so fluffy
half look at it go oh ho look at that
look at that that's really fluffy oh my
god so fluffy super fluffy can I try
yours I'm whisking it no yeah give it a
push
oh okay alright alright and then scoop
like half of it out oh that's not it
come on this part there you go
personality it's like me you gotta come
here I'll take this thing oh yeah look
at this you're a pro you definitely done
this before you mastered the
presentation mine just looks like a
giant peanut yeah little bit alright on
the flip no but you know what it's all
about the taste
yeah Bon Appetit Bon Appetit oh it's
like chewing on the cloud
oh wow that's probably the yummiest air
we're ever gonna do okay where do you go
back to Paris oui oui
we had such an amazing time in Mont
saint-michel and now we're back in Paris
and it's literally so gorgeous here I
know everywhere you look there's just
this beautiful French architecture but
somehow this hotel captures the essence
of New York hmm I think you're right so
I'm being okay I'm just gonna go right
into it so when you first took off the
blindfold I really thought this was
gonna be the dare that you were gonna be
super nervous about but it was the total
opposite you were so excited and you
also had the fastest time which I was
not expecting I don't know I just have
to give you a five I can't give you
anything else crushing the chairs yeah
all right so for your rating Caroline I
actually knew you're gonna be really
excited for your dare you jump right in
the kitchen you're excited to learn your
dance along to the beat you're having a
great time but at the end of the day
your flip kind of a flop so
unfortunately I gotta give you a 3 out
of 5 it's okay
I'll take it the omelets are still
really good I've had a great time it's
probably one of my favorite things I've
ever done
yeah and you'll get them next time all
right let's take a lot of this and go on
to our next adventure
[Music]